hey everyone Merry Christmas hello dad
watching the Steeler game Christmas
Merry Christmas Merry Christmas I've
been vlogging with this prime lens and
guys it's so so so heavy and I can't
really focus it or zoom it so I
basically have to hold this out really
really far let me show you what I look
like in the mirror my dumb crazy we're
shooting all full feature film this
morning we unwrapped all of our
Christmas presents we told our mom this
year that we weren't gonna do Christmas
presents but she still got us Christmas
presents anyway hey the source is she
stalking honey
[Music]
Wow is wild we got a point
[Music]
should I go get the present well thank
you why you here you cut it out that's
what I always want this to be me and
Jenna riding a bike but she won't get ya
because I know you'll know what new
sakis man this is great
these are nice sup yeah you want come
everyone so this is really smart mark
I'm gonna clean everyone's home for that
well this is yeah you come into the
house you get your phone clean please
put your phone in the phone stuff here I
also flew my drone a little bit earlier
today dad I I lost sight of the drone I
didn't know where I couldn't figure out
what where was oh that was so far away
[Music]
so yeah let's uh let's go have some
dinner shall we
Merry Christmas Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas
that's a little holiday cheer we've got
a little wild cold if I can't hurry
hurry hurry go Wow bold my sister's dog
is a little bit crazy so he is currently
right now obsessed with Jenna yesterday
he was super obsessed with me and we
couldn't get him to go away and he was
just going nuts right now Jenna is
currently dealing with crazy crazy Bo
let's get off Jenna
cereal oh wow he does not want to Fran
doesn't believe us that the problem is
because bo is not fixed he's real into
Jenna the telling your mommy about your
baby
so this toy is a what's a call mock
ultrasonic something sounds it's called
a here dog toy it basically makes a
sound that only dogs here because one of
the things that's really annoying is
weaking squeaky dog toys can you guys
hear this no but all the dogs watching
the video the happy day after Christmas
we are going to celebrate by flying some
drones my dad's got his phantoms ready
to go oh gosh didn't loser I couldn't
get it on drowning I couldn't get in
couldn't because my backpack was too big
[Music]
my deadline of three I thought he was a
flying the four that was from my
sister's wedding but he's not he's going
old school he also refuses shafted
firmware because the last time he did
mess up everything
[Music]
get about us
Oh II meant for sleep ordered on here
yeah okay well I'm gonna push the button
and it's gonna go off you hit record
yeah okay
John's first light
okay cool good luck yeah
[Music]
[Music]
let's pack her up so I'm bout to end
this vlog but a lot of you guys were
asking me just see what was the best
Christmas gift you got now this is quite
the interesting gift my mom got this for
all three of us
it's called phone so you basically put
your phone inside of this ultraviolet
box and it disinfects your phone in ten
minutes so let's try it out you can even
charge your phone there's a little USB
port here and you can weed your cord
through here and into the case so let's
just infect our phone shall we set a
timer for ten minutes okay
ten minutes and Counting I'm phone
soaping oh yeah got a thumbs up I didn't
really so you guys can't see that it's
on but it's on it's in there so that
light means it's open did you fall in
self your phone yes and moms and dads
okay ten minutes does it just turn off
into an it's okay see you in ten minutes
[Music]
my gosh my alarm is going off the light
has shut off let's open up our phone so
oh my goodness it just looks so fresh
and clean it just feels feels feels
fresh feels fresh alright guys thanks
for watching I hope you guys had a
lovely Christmas this is a combination
of Christmas and the day after Christmas
so I hope you guys had a wonderful day
happy Boxing Day to those who celebrate
Boxing Day which I'm still not even sure
what that actually is
I'll see you guys in the next vid bye so
we've been doing a little bit of
shopping and I'm not doing a good job at
buying my holiday gifts we're now we're
going to be Apple stores where I plan to
buy most of my present for someone who I
can't say because they probably watch
the video we should get her a strap good
call where's it at over here
check this out as you